hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to this big guys much
closer now this is probably a problem
I'm thinking that maybe I need to do
something differently how buddy okay
that's cool and all but yeah alright
then I'm not sure if I'm messing up cuz
I've recorded these all in a batch but
I'm not sure if I've been messing up by
not turning on the lights
every time I finally found it there it
is my dear diary oh really now
this is the exact same cover the very
same pattern like it was cobbled
together from thick pine boards okay you
found it what does that mean
the first time we learned about the
program was in the fall wait no this is
I already knew about this yeah are you
saying that this was actually the diary
that you were talking about before
because I knew about this I got this way
before but now I guess it's officially
registered okay I guess I'll just flip
through these pages real quick I guess
that's all I need right I wouldn't need
to turn on the lights in the house cuz
everything it's not like I create
anything in this place do I know more
that was it right and if I do this one
more if I get this it happened here in
this forest in this very home what
happened the experimentation is that
what you're talking about just be clear
with me man your mind is going I can't
understand anything you say also just
noticed that he holds different light
sources in this world and the other one
I think this'll that's that's dawn isn't
it
that's dawn in this world isn't it it
looks like it to me
looks like it to you guys right ray-ray
so confused I don't know what to believe
anymore
ah just talk like Christopher Walken
yes isn't Christopher Walken this is my
best Christopher Walken
yeah I got a fever the only prescription
is more care bill more heal bill kid I
gets the more hero gonna please please
can I get some material whoa what are
you what are you what was that who's a
bag of sand whose head was a bag looks
like me you know from nightmare uh or uh
Nightmare Before Christmas you know what
was his name I can't remember
mumsy I was his name I can't remember
the big bag of bugs I can't remember his
name
I'm failing everybody right now I know
yeah what was the name whoa okay well
there's the house that's handy that's
why it's so hard to find these things
sometimes because they're all on
different levels I need to do an
experiment real quick otherwise I'm
gonna lose my mind if I don't find you
all the way around okay see ya Jackie it
won't move back it doesn't do that it
doesn't loop around go now if I wanted
to find it it no there it is that don't
make no sense that don't make no damn
sense that makes zero zero sense that
makes exactly zip doodlee doodlee since
now I've wasted enough time that I don't
know where the hell I'm going I don't
know what the hell I'm doing I don't
even know why anymore you know what
maybe it'd be easier to find the little
girl if I went sideways through the
woods who knows I don't whoa oh damn it
I ran right into it well this really
gonna go sec wool no I think I see
something and then I don't I am I am
balling this one up majorly Oh God Oh
God
and oh good also are there more leaves
falling to normal there's a house again
this doesn't make no damn sense alright
you know what I'm just gonna forego the
little girl for one just one it won't
hurt me because I've I've forgotten
before fine oh god but then they spawn
more of those things ah I don't know
what I'm doing wrong girl I've been
playing this game for like hours and I
still don't know what the hell I'm doing
and it's the same thing it's the same
thing over and over again maybe maybe I
just realized it's the invisible one who
walks around while I'm asleep he's the
only one who was taking my diary and
tearing the pages out I thought that he
might be real and he did appear or is it
time itself time is killing me while I
sleep and I'm watching it happen in my
dreams
that's quite profound that actually is
like a really profound statement I don't
even know if they intended it Tom is
killing me while I or I'm watching time
kill me while I dream what it does that
sometimes why I do that okay whatever
you know what I don't know
oh no anymore all I know is that I'm
running out of time I may have just
royally boned myself by not trying to
find the little girl there but then
again I don't know if it counts against
me if I go game over
I'm thinking maybe do because forget I
don't know what I'm doing I don't think
any oh God right away I haven't even
gotten anything yet oh god a dead end
that's no good yes alright
this house isn't very big is it oh no
wait there's plenty of stuff down here I
thought you were good before I saw that
oh I am different I'm in some other
place I am not doing well my sanity is
almost lost and I haven't even not even
to the door what's at the door the door
at the centre of my mind he thinks that
he's tearing up the diary in his sleep
it feels that while he sleeps he's
eating up his own life I'm so confused
and I feel like I'm doing something
wrong
I feel like I may get the bad end
despite all that I've been trying to do
I've been trying and I should be able to
do it on the first try right I don't
know okay you're all the way up there
don't matter to me I just got to avoid
things that'll make me lose my mind
because my sanity is flowing away Oh
both doors closed how's that fair fagio
a few in the egg after with it I'll be
quick oh you can never tell where they
go oh what oh it got me a good nutmeg
what happened oh gosh dang it
gosh dang it wait how low is might I'll
lose my bar wait no no no I'm only
imagining this this is caused by my
persistent insomnia I have to fall
asleep what is okay I thought my I
thought my little crack at the top of
the screen went down even more oh so
confused her god this is getting really
hard that's what she said
he's not gonna imagine we did do we got
the booty he do okay
do we got the tie me he do it's okay
though long as I make things with my
mind shut up shut up lady
shut your trap hole shut your mouth
before the pies shut your hole I hear
something squishing in the darkness I'm
gonna go this way this time hey now
don't dick with me I don't know why i
ported me before but it did I thought I
had more time but apparently I did not
problem is this glare on my screen I'm
blind out of my right side another time
thing I'm so good Thank You internet
gods for giving me this gift oh oh oh no
oh no yeah waiting around who's tearing
out the pages I don't know but then
again I do not care okay just need maybe
my luck streak will continue and I'll
get one more time machine hey there
Nathan I'm meaning great time and where
are you where are you where are you I'm
not leaving here until I see where you
are I'm not gonna get off this low crap
oh crap I think about Jack well actually
yes I did think about all of the
monsters that could be oh I'm blind
right right there I cannot see a thing
because it's both dark and completely
good I'll bust you out you bastard you
getting frosty out see the light okay oh
god it's a dead end
oh god yeah dad if they come here whoo
what ha you guys see what I've seen it's
a it's my face and a pile of leaves
paint another ladies oh god oh god damn
it I didn't even touch it
oh god damn it I didn't mean to get
poured it here
ah god damn it okay you know what I'm
just gonna wait it out
oh there you are no I'm not gonna find
you it's gonna wait it out here I'm
gonna wait it out not gonna move I tried
got your facehole I'm just gonna wait it
out I got a hiding place and all the
time in the world I don't got a go no
place I don't gotta see nobody I'm gonna
do I do i what excuse you what excuse
you good
no Oh leaves Jaffar yeah oh yeah yeah oh
yeah oh yeah the morning came in this
game you need to move time forward and
the sooner the game ends the better it
is for everyone yeah yeah it's like only
a few more things until the end I'm
assuming that the door means the end
just how close will this [ __ ] be this
time around I'm actually gonna wait and
see just how close he is how close is
you how close are you buddy
Oh ash pretty close down a Goliath
pretty close it's almost done
ah but it'll wait until the next one cuz
I'm all at a time
kinda I'll wait until the next one
anyway so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
thousands another populous millions of
thousands of people Wall freaking
communist
I don't even know that lease is good
I don't know rainbows one
it should be happy fun times
just to aggravated and two out of my mom
but it